or versus Python Python versus are these
two languages are although they're
excellent tools in their own right
very often conceived as being rivals
data science is a field divided you've
got a passion camp and you broaden our
camp and the members of those two groups
each fervently believe that their chosen
tool is superior now I believe but that
the divergence doesn't lie with the
tools it lies with the people you've got
the Python users and you've got the our
users and what is the intersection
between those two groups well it's very
very small they're not an awful lot of
people who are using both Python and R
and within that intersection they're an
even smaller group who are using Python
and are together on the same project now
I have it on good authority that amongst
the most committed are users there are
some who from time to time really really
wish that they had access to the
object-oriented capacities that are
native to Pathan
and similarly amongst the most rabid
Python users there are some who yearn
for the wide range of the statistical
distributions that are available within
our so to pitch these two languages as
being mutually exclusive it's forming a
false dichotomy this there's no inherent
reason why there should be adversary's
really what we should have is them
working together side by side hand in
hand on the same project just to enable
you to do better analytics and and if
you're thinking about Paul McCartney and
Stevie Wonder right now that's no
coincidence
I'm Andrew Collier and I'm talking about
mixed language programming with plasmon
and R as you can see and maybe here I
come from South Africa
I'm a freelance data scientist with top
tell and top tell is a exclusive network
of technical specialists and many
leading companies around the world use
freelancers from top tell to execute
their most critical tasks so these are
some of the tools and technologies that
I'll be talking about if you're active
on Twitter please feel free to use these
liberally and I am data walkie so let's
talk about these two tools and a very
sort of high level sense according to a
survey posted by red monk in the first
quarter of this year both python and r
are very very highly rated on both Stack
Overflow in terms of questions posted
and answered as well as on github in
terms of overall number of commits so
these objectively there's very little to
choose between the two of them and if
you look at these rankings over time
then you can see that Pathan has been
consistently highly rated overall as a
development language this is data
science aside for a number of years and
are currently sitting in 13th position
has been gradually gaining traction over
the years let's take a look at the
features of our it is literally the
grand Dom of data science since its
inception in 1995 it's captured a
significant proportion of the data
science industry although it's more
dominant in academia than in in commerce
in the process it's built up an enormous
volume of packages so cran currently has
an excess of 10,000 packages they're
also a very large number of bulton
datasets which means that for newcomers
to are it's very easy to get started
because the data is already there it's a
wide range of numerical and statistical
capabilities within the language and the
documentation as I'm going to show you a
little bit later is really quite superb
although it can be a little bit opaque
at times it's difficult to get into it
especially when you're starting out are
really excels for standalone analyses
and it has two principal drawbacks to my
mind and that is that sometimes it can
be a complete memory hog and once your
RAM is a
sauce turd your machine starts to swap
out and then everything grinds to a halt
the learning curve is also pretty steep
but once you get over that initial hump
and you realize that it's pretty cool
it's plain sailing
what am i Python well Python is a bit of
a debutantes on the data science scene I
mean the language itself has been around
since the early 1990s but in terms of
data science applications it's only a
relative newcomer with the advent of
libraries like pandas and scikit-learn
it's an explicitly object-oriented
language and opposition to our and this
means that it's very easy to write nice
well-structured code and Python really
excels for integration with other
systems and this is maybe one of the
weak sides of our as I mentioned it
doesn't have any native data science
capabilities so you have to include
these additional modules to get started
with data science in Python and there
are these issues with module
dependencies that you have to resolve
very often by using virtual environments
well look at take a look at that - so my
question is how can we leverage the best
capabilities of both languages and the
idea here is to mix the two of them
together so to look at a blend of path
and nr and this idea is by no means new
in fact I think that most of us wouldn't
think twice about embedding a chunk of
sequel into either an R or Python script
right so why would we hesitate about
mixing up path and and R it's really
it's this exactly the same principle so
there are a couple of ways that one
could go about doing this the one
approach is you spin up an R interpreter
and then you somehow incorporate Python
into that or you take the other approach
and that is you run Python and somehow
consume an R script or alternatively you
can you could in principle have both R
and path and running in parallel and yet
some other environment that's one option
that we're going to explore this
afternoon so let's start off by looking
at the possibility of using
within a Pathan environment and they're
actually a number of existing approaches
to this problem so there are at least
three modules that allow you to do this
and we got to focus our attention on the
third one and that's our pi/2 since it's
the one that's been most aggressively
developed at present you can install our
part to very easily with poop and
there's also a nice docker image which
means that you can play around with this
technology without making any major
commitments right let's um let's see how
this works in practice so I'm going to
be running all of this in a jiff to
netbook and what I would do is start off
by just learning up a couple of
libraries before I do that I'm going to
turn off warnings because once you start
running your inside path when you
discover that it produces a lot of
warnings the majority of which are
pretty uninformative so we got to turn
those off and load up an umpire panas
and scikit-learn and then also another
component of our to par which is to
allow us to easily move data back and
forth between our and pandas dataframes
and then before we get started with the
actual analysis I'm going to create a
couple of data sets both of them
randomized so some uniform uniformly
distributed ages between 0 and 18 and
then some hats that are related to those
ages so 2 arrays and then package those
arrays together in a data frame that
ends up looking something like that so
an age column and a height column and
ultimately what we're doing is making a
couple of plots with this and our and
also fitting a linear model right so
let's get started with running our in
Jupiter in order to do this we're gonna
use the the Jupiter integration there's
also a high level and a low level
interface that allow you to interact
with our but we've used the tubes
integration because I think that's
probably what the majority of people are
using for their data science projects in
order to make that available you have to
load up this extension and then you have
to magic commands available to you so
that the cell level magic which is the
double percentage R and then the line
level magic
a single percentage are if we just take
a look at how those work and practice if
we want to evaluate a chunk of our code
with the inline magic then we simply
specify our code and we proceeded with
the magic and when we execute that we
get back the corresponding piece of data
from our and here may be just a couple
of explanations one is that if you're a
Python developer you might expect these
periods to have some significance they
don't in our a period can simply be a
components of a variable name and this
dollar is actually more like the dot
operator in R so what we're doing here
is looking at this variable called r dot
version and we're extracting from it the
component called version dot string okay
let's do something else then we're going
to generate a vector of normally
distributed random numbers assign them
to a variable called hats and R and then
return the results to to pass on as an
umpire array so that's very very nice
the translation from our tapassin is
pretty seamless I guess the majority of
us are more interested in looking at
tabular data and R in Python and that
integration works very smoothly as well
as I mentioned before I has a number of
books and data sets and one of them is
called MT cause some characteristics or
some many old vehicles so what we can do
is looking at the first six records of
that in R we can pull straight through
into pathan and it arrives as a panda's
data frame and of course you can then go
and consume that as part of your
analysis then within within Python we
can also make assignments directly from
these magic variables so for example we
can assign the output from the in-line
magic to a variable and this means that
that will then become available in
Python environment if I can type in the
soul all right
hmm yep there we go okay so there's the
data frame this has been pulled directly
through from our and then this is what
the the soul level magic looks like
right you execute our function and our
chunk of our code and the entire block
is evaluated nothing actually gets
returned we'll see how we pass
information back and forth from the cell
level magic right now yes yes it can the
translation is not particularly neat you
have to run another function which I'm
going to show you presently to actually
translate that neatly into into pandas
okay so let's just look at a couple of
applications the first of them is going
to be generating a regression model and
what I'm going to do is using the minus
i argument to the magic I'm going to
pass in these two variables
aegeon height and then within R I'm
going to use the LM function to form a
linear model between those two so we
read this first argument is give me a
model for height the till there is read
as a function of age assign the results
for a variable called fit and then use
the correct function to extract the
coefficients from that model assign them
to another variable in R and then use
the minus o for output argument from the
magic two plus the theta then back to
Python and one thing it's worth
mentioning here is the assignment
operator in our if you're writing truly
idiomatic R then you use this assignment
operator rather than a single equal sign
although a single equal sign will do
work just as well so if we evaluate that
you'll note that the actual block
doesn't return anything but now if we
take a look at the coefficients we see
aha
we've got back the coefficients freak
first the ones that we actually used
when we both the data but if we take a
look at that we actually see that these
coefficients are currently not actually
a part of an a today our path and data
structure we actually have to make this
conversion and this is the function that
I was referring to
if you
use that then it will actually go and
make the appropriate conversions for you
from arch Python and we can then take a
look at a summary of the model and this
I think is one of the arguments in favor
of doing this kind of modeling and our
rather than Python and that is that you
don't get these kind of mass diagnostics
in scikit-learn yeah we can have the the
p values associated with each of the
coefficients that's pretty difficult to
get out of out of scikit-learn okay so
let's take a look at another application
and that is plotting what about
generating our plot was just base R so
here's something super simple just
plotting a series of integers firstly
specifying that we want to just inflate
the text size ever so slightly so the
folk at the back and see and then
plotting those integers choosing red for
the point color and opaque disks for the
actual plotting symbols and there we
have a very nice but not particularly
fancy plot what about something a little
bit more interesting R has built-in
Diagnostics associated with the majority
of its models and we can actually go and
plot out a couple of diagnostic curves
associated with that linear regression
model that we built a moment ago so
that's what we see there so these are
things that will allow us to diagnose
just exactly how well this regression
works so one of the questions you have
to ask when you're doing a regression
model is does my data satisfy the
requirements or the assumptions behind
this model and these two plots allow us
to assess that so for example on the
left hand side we have a plot of
residuals versus the fitted values and
we are hoping they're not to have some
sort of a systemic effect where the
residuals are getting larger or smaller
as the fitted values change and
similarly on the right hand side here we
have a quantile quantile plot which
allows us to assess whether those
residuals are normally distributed or
not final example of plotting is using
the ggplot2 add-on package and our so
this is a very commonly used package if
you're wanting to make sort of
presentation quality plots in our and
it's built on this idea of the grammar
of graphics where you essentially build
up a plot by superimposing a whole
series of layers until you have your
final product so we start off with the
growing data frame that we're passing in
as
input arguments to the magic and
choosing the age and hottest x and
y-values putting on some scatter points
and then a smoother which is discard is
superimpose the linear fit with some
conference and falls and we end up with
a rather nice well I guess pretty close
publication quality plot okay
so final illustration of the use of our
within Python is generating some
synthetic data and this is something
that I have to do fairly routinely
because I have models and I'm bullying I
don't have any real data to train them
on so I want to build some synthetic
data for them and I have no doubt that
they're good libraries and paths and for
doing that but in our there's a great
library called charlatans and it does
this job magnificently well so I'm going
to load up the library charlatan and I'm
going to generate some synthetic people
and I'm gonna do this just because I can
in a French low-cost so I'm gonna be
generating some French names some phone
numbers and job descriptions let's go
ahead and do that and I think those all
look pretty French to me and we can we
can add some stuff to that as well so
supposing we want to put in a company
name as well we can have synthetic
people company and we can use this
company function to generate another one
of those ten and of course we want that
to be in the same low call right add
those in and take a look at what the
synthetic people look like back in
Python and as you can see it and kind of
most looks like a panda's data frame but
not quite and that's because the
translation doesn't happen automatically
with this cell level magic but we can
easily do that by using that translation
function and there you end up with a
very very nice valid pandas dataframe
which you can then incorporate into the
rest of your analysis okay as I
mentioned before there there's also a
lower level and a slightly higher level
interface and and these allow you to
basically twiddle with things if the the
Jupiter interact and integration doesn't
work
particularly well for your particular
problem okay so let's go back to the
presentation and thinking about doing
things the other way around and that is
incorporating pattern into your our
workflow presuming that you have an auto
workflow and again there are a number of
packages that allow you to do this and
we could be talking principally about
the final one called reticulate and this
is a library that's been very
aggressively developed by our studio
which is the IDE one of the ideas for
our and articulate is available on cran
so there's a nice stable version but if
you want to live closer to the bleeding
edge you can also install it directly
from github so let's take a look at how
that works so the first thing we do is
we load up the reticulate package
obviously and there we go and then we
gonna load up two more packages one
called magic and this is going to just
allow us to produce some magic squares
again I'm sure it's possible to do this
in Python but there's a magic package
and R which I'm going to use just for
generating some test data and I'm also
gonna use my greeter which is a really
recent package and our but it's become
very pervasive because it provides this
path and having the papen are allows you
to write some of the most elegant code
you can imagine okay so I guess one of
the first things we should do is check
with there's a path an executable on my
machine and I guess yes there is there
we go it happens to be the path into
executable which is a little bit
disappointing but if I run my config
then I see that the reticulate package
actually although it picks up this as
the the default interpreter that's
because it's the first match on my path
it also recognizes that there are a
couple of other interpreters available
so there's also a Python 3 in the same
folder and there's a Python interpreter
in a virtual environment sitting in my
home folder ok we can actually choose to
use one of those alternative
interpreters by using the used path and
function the only caveat to that is it
has to be the first function that you
run off
you load the package as soon as you
start interacting with path and as you
go to see in a moment it actually binds
to a particular version of the
interpreter and once that's happened
it's hard to go back okay so I suppose
that one of the principal reasons that
one would want to explore this
integration is to take advantage of all
of pythons cool packages and the way
that this works and reticulated is very
nice
you run the import function and it
effectively takes the entire package and
assigns it to a variable in R so for
example if you wanted to access what you
would normally do with sistered version
in python you would do such dollar
version and an R so that's very
transparent it works for attributes
within modules but it also works just as
well for for functions and those modules
as well so for example if we load up the
OS module we then have access to all of
its capabilities and we can see for
example we can get the current working
directory and compared to the the
corresponding thing generated directly
within R we can also list the files in
that current directory and do the same
thing in R so as you would expect the
results are exactly the same but the
reason that I mentioned these functions
is because my next thing is to look at
the Associated documentation and as I
mentioned before the documentation in
ours is really really good so just
looking at this essentially quite simple
file I function at least we see that the
documentation for list files is really
very extensive there's a lot there and
what I think is one of the nicest
aspects about ours documentation is at
the end of each of these pages there's
an example section that's generally
where I start when I'm trying to
understand a new function see it a
couple of use cases and then once I've
kind of got my head around how to use
the function I'll then go back and try
and digest all of this other information
we can also access the Associated Python
documentation directly from within R now
as well but as I think you will agree
relative to the our documentation for
the corresponding function this is
somewhat tests
right so as I said before you sometimes
have these dependency issues between
modules and paths man and you get around
this by having virtual environments and
you can actually set up these virtual
environments and interact with them very
nicely from within R as well so let's
take a look at where these version
environments live on my machine and
they're in this hidden folder in my in
my home directory so virtual
environments and I can list the ones
that I have available
there's just the single one called test
which I created for this demonstration
if the environment is not existing
already we can create one from within R
as well by running this virtual
environment create command of course
that's not going to do anything right
now because the environment really
exists we can check on what the
configuration of that environment is and
we can see that by default it's hooked
up with the path and to interpreter
which is probably not ideal and
currently that the developers for
reticulate are working on a more robust
way for you to actually select the
interpreter that you've got to associate
with a particular new virtual
environment and the objective with this
of course is to start installing modules
and we can do this as well from within
our by just specifying a vector of
module names and reticulate will then go
and run pip for each of those and
execute the install process and right
now all I want to do is hook up with
this virtual environment and start doing
things so I say right to use that
virtual environment and start importing
libraries and the first thing I get is
an error that's kind of disappointing
isn't it but there's a good reason for
this and it's what I said before about
particulate binding through a particular
environment right it's now hooked up
with two paths and two if I want to
change to the Python interpreter in a
different work virtual environment and
then need to actually detach myself from
reticulate and then reattach so that I
can hook up with a different interpreter
so I detach and then reattach and I'm
now really working in that virtual
environment I can go and check that all
of those modules that I answer
all on our available and I can load them
up so let's start actually doing things
in Python and I'm going to generate some
data and are using that magic function
so this is just going to be a 7 by 7
matrix so these magic squares are just a
little mathematical oddity where all the
sum the sums of the columns and the rows
are all exactly the same so we can
validate that in our or these rows and
cons all sum to 175 as does the
principal diagonal but now if you're
wanting to do manipulation on this
matrix in Python then we can access
functions within numpy directly so for
example if I want to use the transfer
function in vampire it's just an umpire
dollar transfers and I provide the
argument my our matrix and there I get
the transpose I can calculate the eigen
values and the eigen vectors of course I
could have done all of this natively in
R but the idea here is to illustrate
just how easy it is to shift data like a
compound data structures across the path
and now I hope that you're concerned I
was concerned about taking an enormous
matrix and literally copying there
across the path and and in standing
there stuffing the results back that
sounds like an awful lot of information
moving around but in fact it's it's
super efficient because your our process
and your path and process are actually
memory mapped together so they are
looking at precisely the same data
structures there's no copying back and
forth taking place which makes the
entire process super efficient ok what
about actually executing some code well
this is very straightforward we can
power n string that will execute the
string in the Python interpreter we can
also run in an entire file with using
power and file and whatever variable
we've then creates it for example in
Python I've just created a variable
called X and given a value of 10 I can
then access with an R using this special
object called pi so pi $1 will give me
access to that I can assign to that
directly from within R so this is not a
read-only relationship there it's
worthwhile pointing out that numerix in
our floating point by default so you
might expect
that to be a 13 integer in Python it's
not because it's gonna be a really
floating point in our and we can create
new variables using this same process as
well so this is very transparent way of
interacting with variables present in
your path and interpreter but probably
what's an even greater utility is this
source path and function and this
actually allows you to source an entire
Python file and all of the objects that
are created then become first-class to
variables within R so let's just take a
look at what that file has it I'm
creating a simple class called person
and then a couple of objects called Emma
and storm and if I source that and then
go and take a look at Emma and storm
notice there's no pie dollar prefix on
these these are actually first class
variables and R then I see that the
contents of those two objects and a very
very cool thing if you're our user is
the fact that I can now actually
instantiate these classes directly in
our alright so I defined a class in
Python but I can now actually generate
instances of it directly in R so I'm
creating a Claire and I'm creating an
Elizabeth by just passing through the
arguments to there constructors and I
can access their attributes write the ID
the name and the birthdate I can also
run methods on those objects it's all
very straightforward and pretty much
what you'd expect to be but I still feel
it's a whole lot of magic it's this kind
of capability is huge if you're an AR
developer you can also launch the ripple
from within R and this means that you
can actually start running interactive
code so note that this is not our
anymore I'm actually interacting
directly with the Python interpreter
here and I'm tapping in laughs code
that's being evaluated live a great
thing here though is the fact that once
I'm in the Python ripple I'm able to
access variables from R as well so for
example there's an iris data frame in
our I can now access that from within
- by using the our special object so r
dot aris now gives me access to the iris
data from our so this viewing happens
from both sides like the python
interpreter can see are through the path
and our interpreter I can see passing
through the park which is exceedingly
cool and the other thing is that this
the stateís structure that we're viewing
from python is actually going to be
interpreted as a data frame so there we
go we can run ahead on it and get the
first five records from the Python
perspective this is a panda's data frame
okay so the chairman has just indicated
me it's time to wrap this up so I will
do that I hope that I've impressed upon
you that that will integrating
ironpython
is a a cool thing to do but it also
expands the range of possibilities using
our PI - and reticulate it's actually
pretty straightforward to do this as an
our developer my preference would
definitely be to go the reticulate route
I also just think that the integration
there is a little bit better but of
course depending on on your choice of
language your opinion may vary okay I
think that both these languages are
really important and that any data
scientist should be at least conversant
in both of them and I think this is a
very nice way of accessing both
languages does this need to be an
exclusive relationship hell no we can
divide our allegiances between them no
there's no reason why you shouldn't
serve two masters or have two lovers so
and this enables you to get the best of
both worlds
if there are any questions I'd be happy
to answer them quickly
[Applause]
hi I thanks for the talk
I'm using both but not together so far
but so this will be my next challenge do
I understand you correctly that if I'm
using our out of Python that the memory
is not shared and if I then swap big
amount of data then this can be a mess
yes so that is my understanding of what
happens in our part two is that you
don't have this it's not memory mapped
I'd I stand to be corrected on that
point but that's my understanding yes
whereas if you take the reticulate route
then there's no overhead associated with
moving data back and forth Thanks I
think that's a very strong argument to
run reticulate